hallo leute zurück bei kali antwortet
ich beantworte wieder eure fragen zu
unseren videos zur deutschen sprache und
kultur erste frage heute kommt von jet
war so großartig wie immer danke ich
habe in frage für das nächste video wenn
ihr sie im nächsten video anschließen
möchten haben die deutschen irgendeine
meinung oder auch keine meinung über die
kandidaten die sich jetzt um das
präsidentenamt in den usa bewerben
ich komme aus den usa und finde es sehr
immer sehr interessant was die leute aus
anderen ländern denken über die usa ja
tatsächlich das ist ein thema und wir
haben ja schon öfters über das
deutsch-amerikanische verhältnis
gesprochen amerika ist ja so ein
bisschen wie ein großer bruder für
deutschland und so macht man sich neben
den ganzen positiven sachen die es gibt
auch gerne mal lustig wenn irgendwas
schief läuft und zum beispiel donald
trump ist natürlich auch in deutschland
ein begriff und ist ein gefundenes
fressen für die medien genauso wie in
den usa auch in deutschland also der
kommt schon häufiger mal vor in den
nachrichten
hillary clinton natürlich auch und
generell kann man sagen dass die
deutschen das politische geschehen in
den usa schon sehr genau verfolgen weil
es ist eine der wichtigsten verbündeten
und der wichtigsten partner von
deutschland und wenn man das mit anderen
ländern vergleicht wo man in deutschland
gar nicht weiß wer dort überhaupt
regiert da kann man sagen dass es in
deutschland schon sehr genau verfolgt
wird und sogar auch viele berichte gibt
es und es wird zum beispiel auch live
übertragen
in der wahlnacht zum beispiel das gibt
es glaube ich sonst aus keinem land der
welt
eric stratmann oder eric statement
schreibt was denken die leute über
angela merkel ja das eine frage ist ganz
einfach zu beantworten alle lieben
angela merkel
okay das war natürlich ein scherz nicht
alle lieben angela merkel aber ist es
interessant man wir haben überlegt dafür
diese frage auf der straße stellen und
tatsächlich um uns erst mal dagegen
entschieden weil jetzt in diesem moment
würden fast alle leute nur mit dem thema
flüchtlinge pro und contra argumentieren
also ich glaube dass das thema so über
wie
wäre und dann hätten wir wieder ein eine
zweite episode zum thema flüchtlinge das
wollen wir erst mal nicht machen
vielleicht stimmlich thema später
nochmal
generell kann man sagen dass sie relativ
populär ist in deutschland wenn man das
so vergleicht und sie ist auch gott dort
also zumindest akzeptiert von den leuten
die sie nicht gewählt haben ich zum
beispiel habe sie nicht gewählt und
würde sie wahrscheinlich beim nächsten
mal auch nicht wählen
ich sage jetzt nicht welche partei ich
wähle was wechselt auch immer aber
trotzdem kann man sagen dass viele leute
relativ zufrieden mit ihr sind sie macht
keine besonders zweimal starke politik
in die eine oder die andere richtung und
ist so mehr der ruhige typ wie man ja
auch weiß und das finden die deutschen
grundsätzlich ohne dass ich das jetzt so
ganz vor allgemeiner möchte erstmal ganz
gut auch wie sie sich eigentlich in der
flüchtlingskrise verhält sind die
meisten deutschen eigentlich relativ
zufrieden damit es gibt natürlich immer
solche und solche es gibt auch die
rechten die sagen alles ist scheiße es
gibt die linken sagen alles scheiße es
gibt in der mitte leute die sagen alles
scheiße wenn man schon was
verallgemeinern sagen will gibt immer
solche zu unserer episode europa gab es
natürlich wieder wieder diskussionen
über das thema flüchtlinge weil es auch
in dem thema präsent war schreibt denn
die smv easyjet vielen dank für die
videos nach meinem empfinden glaube ich
dass die idee dass europa den
flüchtlingen helfen sollte geht ohne
frage aber ich muss fragen sind sie echt
davon überzeugt dass flüchtlinge die
mehrheit der menschen sind
oder ist es ihnen deutlich dass viele
aus wirtschaftlichen gründen kommen ja
das ist immer wieder die gleiche frage
und immer wieder die gleiche diskussion
sind dass ein wirklich eigentlich
flüchtlinge oder sind das nur
wirtschaftsmigranten dazu sage ich nun
mal gegen frage glaubst du wirklich dass
leute ihr leben riskieren in klapprigen
boten über das mittelmeer kommen
tausende von kilometern zu fuß laufen
nur um hier in einem völlig überfüllten
flüchtlingscamp zu sitzen in dem das
leben echt beschissen ist
ich glaube schon dass die meisten
tatsächlich aus not kommen weil sonst
würden sie das alles nicht auf sich
nehmen und man muss auch mal andersrum
rechnen und nicht immer in kategorien
und schubladen denken menschen die von
einer wirtschaftlichen existenz so also
von einer wirtschaftlichen notlage so
bedroht sind dass ihre existenz in frage
ist dass sie nicht mehr genug zu essen
haben
die sind auch in not genauso wie leute
bei dem krieg zu hause ist und so muss
man immer genau auf den pfeil auf den
einzelfall gucken man kann ich sagen die
sind falsche migranten das und richtig
mir gerade so was gibt es nicht
ja er ist getan schreibt helau people
i'm a big fan of the big easy german
fashion week makes famous bei john
cleese und fawlty towers don't mention
haut das vancouver-ticket german people
aboard the wall ist tabu it's one thing
vdsf als coming from english speaking
countries am australian living in
germany in hamburg
german backpacker blues auf der kommode
fremdarbeiter backpacking days and how
to talk about worldwatch ja was kann man
dazu sagen zu dem thema über das thema
haben wir schon mal geredet
ich empfinde das soja als als junge
halbwegs junge deutsche die den krieg ja
selber nicht miterlebt hat nicht mal
meine eltern haben den krieg miterlebt
weiß ich natürlich was passiert ist und
ich habe dass das gefühl oder ich denke
dass wir als junge generation ja alle
vor diesen krieg stehen vor dem was
passiert ist und ein gehabt jetzt aus
australien kommt oder aus amerika oder
aus england wir alle empfinden das was
damals passiert das als tragödie dort
sind millionen von menschen gestorben
und das ist schon eine ernste sache und
was ich verstehen kann wenn zum beispiel
deine freundin sagt sie wurde ständig
darauf angesprochen ist ja immer die
frage wie wirst du darauf angesprochen
es stimmt dass in vielen teilen der welt
umso weiter man weg ist von deutschland
die leute wenig über deutschland wissen
und vielleicht ist das das einzige was
sie wissen was wir als deutsche sind ja
auch so ein bisschen ernster dann
komisch finden oder auch manchmal dorf
in das wehrleute ankommen und erstmal
mit einem witz einsteigen sagen so hardy
nazi oder harrach erlebt hitler noch das
habe ich auch schon ganz oft erlebt
meistens denke ich komme das einfach aus
unwissen und dann erkläre ich erstmal
also ich rede natürlich darüber wir
reden alle darüber und du kannst auch
jeden von uns ansprechen will können wir
gerne mal drüber diskutieren aber es ist
immer die frage wie du jemand anspricht
wenn du auf einer party wisst und das
erste was du sagst du machst einen witz
über den zweiten weltkrieg dann kann es
sein dass das nicht immer so ganz gut
ankommt weil wir deutschen letzte frei
für heute kommt von yaz herr abdullah
versagt da er auf meine frage immer noch
nicht geantwortet habe stelle ich sie
noch mal könnt ihr bitte mal eine elle
in einer episode illustrieren wie man
die umgangssprache lernt ja lieber ja
das illustrieren wir quasi in jeder
episode denn umgangssprache ist
tatsächlich etwas was uns mir persönlich
zum beispiel beim sprachenlernen in der
schule oder in den büchern gefehlt hat
deswegen machen wir sie dämmen und das
ist die ganze idee hinter easy german
das heißt wenn der umgangssprache lernen
möchtest dann kann man das nicht in
einer episode lernen sondern du kannst
das dadurch lernen dass du immer wieder
zu höchst- und deshalb machen wir sie
german weil viele menschen zum beispiel
nicht in deutschland sind sondern in
brasilien oder china oder australien in
einer schulklasse sitzen und sie können
dort so wie ich französisch gelernt habe
zwei oder drei jahre im buch studieren
und dann fahren sie in das land in
deutschland nach deutschland in diesem
fall wohl verstehen auf der straße
nichts weil es gibt umgangssprachliche
redewendung es gibt verkürzung ist
länger es gibt es redewendungen die man
wir in den büchern nicht findet und
genau das machen wir eigentlich mit all
unseren videos konversationen auf der
sprache straße du wirst sehen
unterschiedliche generationen
unterschiedliche soziale gruppen reden
anders und zum beispiel auch die
redewendung episoden die wir machen dass
es die ganze idee hinter siegerin also
ich kann dir die sprache nicht sofort
beibringen aber wenn du ab und an unsere
folgen guckst dann hoffe ich dass du
mehr lernen wirst das war's schon wieder
für diese woche wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen
wir hoffen ihr habt noch mehr fragen wir
freuen uns auf eure fragen ich hatte
wieder sehr viele fragen diese woche ich
konnte leider nicht alle beantworten
aber schickt sie weiter wir versuchen
auch manchmal was schriftlich zu
beantworten
danke fürs zuschauen und danke für eure
unterstützung vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren und uns auf panels
hier unterstützen wenn euch unser
programm gefällt und bis zum nächsten
woche ciao